okay well I asked uh two people coming
into this things I should ask you one of
them was Josh Hart he said please just
you know say how was Josh busting his
ass so much in college so that is the
question from from
Josh never I was told brba ever tell you
that Josh was a bully in college oh
please tell me oh let's tell the story
um I was a freshman young freshman
18 and we was in practice and we have
like this side out of bounds play that
we run every single time so obviously on
defense like I know the play so he calls
me a hack but like yeah I think he was
upset because I was like packing him up
you know in practice just cooking him a
little bit just on defense on defense on
defense and I got aggressive with him
and he's about to go over screen I just
like got up on him and he just Josh was
wild and he just
like picked me up like right when I went
and just threw me like just threw me
like just threw me I'm everybody was
like everybody knows job Josh like yo I
was so mad like I didn't look at him I
didn't talk to him I was just like off
him right yeah and me and Jos weren't
really the closest when I first got
there and I I think maybe just because
like young guy coming in and you know
he's probably trying to seert that down
it's like you like I'm not going to tiet
but I'm just here to you know yeah and
we weren't even that close then and I
think from after that moment I remember
I I wasn't talking like I came in
practice like I probably talked for like
a day like I was just like off everybody
mad like I'm just mad yeah like he tried
it yeah I'm just mad and I remember I
went home and Josh like text me I know
where it's like you good like no but I
was like yeah and then like actually
ever ever since then like we got super
close and like like best friends now so
yeah that was hilarious I was like so
mad at his ass he's a bully he was like
what you bully me for what I do I just
came in just trying to play hard man I
just have to say that is such like a man
apology just you good you good I'm like
didn't talk about what happened just
like just checking in on making sure
you're okay but ever since then y'all
are good yeah for sure I love that story
okay well then the other person I asked
was Donovan Mitchell and he said that I
should actually force you to pick your
favorite uh Villanova inba teammate so
who in the league of course I say that
is he said who in the league that went
to fanova was your favorite
teammate
I will
only I'll have I'll have to say I'll
have to say jayen because I have to say
jayen
because he was our point guard and he
pretty much gave me a lot of my looks
and got me kind of like you know got me
average of 18 points so got me to the
league so I you know shout out to the
little Point guy a little little Doan
over
there